هذه التوابيت مليئة بجثث جنودكم.
وسنرسل لكم الكثير من الجثث في
الايام القادمة. فقد انتهت
مهلتكم. هكذا اعلنها طباخ بوتين.
وشولسي يعلن ان وقت انهاء الحرب
لم يحن بعد. والجيش الروسي يقضي
على افضل وحدة اوكرانية مدربة.
ولاول مرة موسكو تدخل قنابل
تدميرية هائلة في الحرب
الاوكرانية. ومجزرة روسية ارواح
سبعمائة جندي اوكراني خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة روسية لاربع دول
عربية. الصين ترفع ميزانيتها
العسكرية وامريكا تحذر تايوان من
اقتراب الحرب. والرجل الاصفر
اقصد ترامب ساوقف الحرب
الاوكرانية في اربع وعشرين ساعة
فقط. بينما الحلفاء يتدربون عشرة
ايام بلياليها لمواجهة الشمالية
وبيونج يانج تحذر العراق لا
للكحول بعد اليوم. وماكرون في
موقف محرج وضابط لبناني يضرب
ضابطا اسرائيليا حاول دخول
بلاده. مخازن الموت الروسي. اخر
من الضربات الروسية الكثيفة
والقصف لا يتوقف برا وجوا. لتخرج
التقارير الغربية معلنة عن
انسحاب تدريجي للقوات من مدينة
باخموت لكن المعارك العنيفة عادت
من جديد بعد انتهاء مهلة اخراج
المدنيين في المدينة. بينما اكدت
القوات الروسية انها حاصرت
المدينة من كل اطرافها. فهل نشهد
ماريبو الاخرى? من جهته نفى
الجيش الاوكراني الانسحاب
الجماعي من باخموت مؤكدا ان
المعارك تدور في ضواحي المدينة.
وكليف تتعهد بالدفاع عن المدينة
لاطول وقت ممكن من اسبوع صعب
هناك. وها هو الطباخ يظهر من
جديد مع شحنة اخرى من التوابيت
والجثث. قال انها لمقاتلين
اوكران عادة ما يوجه حديثه
للرئيس الاوكرانيسكي. ليعلن
المتحدث باسم وزارة الدفاع
الروسية ايجور كوناشينكوف عن
مذبحة قامت بها القوات الروسية
لتقضي على نحو سبعمائة عسكري
وتدمر اليات واسلحة خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة في محوري ليمان
ودونيسك باقليم دومباس. فعن اي
مجزرة نتحدث ومن مجازر البر الى
الدمار الجوي. حيث استخدمت
الطائرات الروسية ولاول مرة
قنابل اب ايه بي في ذات القدرة
التدميرية الكبيرة في ابدي ابكا
وهذه القنابل مخصصة لتدمير
الاهداف المحصنة على مسافة الى
اربعين كيلو مترا. وتلقى من
ارتفاع لا يقل عن اربعة عشر
كيلومتر وذلك وفق وكالة ان نيوز
الروسية لتصبح المواقع
الاوكرانية المحصنة في مهب
الريح. ليتجه وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويجو لتفقد تجمع القوات
الروسية فوستوك جنوبي دونتسكا في
منطقة العملية العسكرية الخاصة.
بينما اجرى شويجو اجتماعا مع
قادة عسكريين للتخطيط المقبلة في
اوكرانيا فما الذي يخطط لوشويجو
يا ترى؟ في المقابل وصل وزير
العدل الامريكي في زيارة مفاجئة
للفيف المدينة الكبرى في غرب
اوكرانيا فيما التقت رئيسة
البرلمان الاوروبي روبرت ميتسولا
بالزينسكي في الفيف ايضا داعية
لتقديم اسلحة اضافية الى
اوكرانيا ليأتي الرد من المستشار
الالماني اولفشولتس الذي عبر عن
استعداد الغرب لتقديم ضمانات امن
محددة لاوكرانيا لكن بعد انتهاء
النزاع وقال ان الوقت لم يحن بعد
لهذا الامر بحسب شبكة سي ان ان.
الدواء لا يفيد بعد ان يموت
شخصيا هذا فعن اي ضمانات تتحدث.
وهنا يعود طباخ بوتين مرة اخرى.
ليطلق تصريحا مفاجئا قائلا يجب
ان نناضل من اجل روسيا. والا فان
اوكرانيا بمساعدة الناتو ستختار
الخطوط الحمراء مجددا ولن تنتهي
العملية العسكرية قريبا.
وبالعودة للحرب الاوكرانية قال
ضباط اوكرانيون انه تم القضاء
على احدى افضل الوحدات تدريبا من
القوات الاوكرانية في منطقة
ارتيموفيسك في الاشهر الاخيرة
وذلك وفق وول ستريت جورنال.
لتفتح موسكو احضانها للعرب. حيث
اوضح نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي
جيني ايفانوف ان روسيا على
اتفاقيات لالغاء تأشيرات الدخول
للمواطنين الروس مع احدى عشرة
دولة بما في ذلك اربع دول عربية
هي البحرين وعمان والسعودية
والكويت بحسب صحيفة الوئام
السعودية. وبين هذا وذاك عاد
المستشار الالماني شولتس ليعلن
بان بلاده اصبحت مستقلة عن
امدادات الغاز والنفط والفحم من
روسيا دون ان يؤدي هذا الى ازمة
اقتصادية. عسكرية صينية. يدا بيد
وخطوة بخطوة يرفع التنين الصيني
من قدراته العسكرية. وبعد
التوترات الاخيرة مع الولايات
المتحدة اعتزمت الصين رفع
ميزانيتها العسكرية بنسبة سبعة
فاصل اثنين بالمائة للعام الحالي
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين لتصل الى
نحو مائتين واربعة وعشرين مليار
وثمانمائة مليون دولار وفقا
لمسودة الدولة الصينية لتعلن
بكين ذلك بانه استجابة للتحديات
الامنية المعقدة والوفاء
بالتزامات بلد كبير. فهل هو من
اجل مواجهة الامريكان ام
لاستعادة تايوان يا اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. وهنا رئيس الوزراء
الصيني لكاتشانج يقول ان بكين
تتمسك بمبدأ صين واحدة الذي ينص
على ان تايوان جزء من الصين. هذه
التصريحات الصينية تايوان لترفض
الحكومة التايوانية وبشدة
مطالبات بكين بالسيادة عليها
وتقول ان سكان الجزيرة البالغ
عددهم ثلاثة وعشرين مليونا هم
فقط من يمكنهم تقرير مستقبلهم.
وماذا بعد الرفض يا هؤلاء? في
سياق اخر خرج الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب متوعدا
بمحاسبة الصين على اطلاقها فيروس
كورونا على حد قوله. كوريا
الشمالية تعلن استعدادها.
التوترات تعود لشبه الجزيرة
الكورية. وتأبى واشنطن وسيول الا
ان تعيد بيونج يانج الى الواجهة
حيث تم الاعلان عن التدريبات
العسكرية المشتركة بين امريكا
وكوريا الجنوبية في الثالثة عشر
من الشهر الجاري. ولمدة عشرة
ايام متواصلة هذه المناورة التي
تدعى بدرع الحرية لمحاكاة
تهديدات كوريا الشمالية
المحتملة. تنتقد كوريا الشمالية
مناورة درع الحرية هذه. قائلة
انها بروفا لغزو كوريا الشمالية
طبقا لما ذكرته شبكة الاذاعية
الكورية الجنوبية. ولهذا السبب
تحديدا تسعى كوريا الشمالية
لتعزيز امكانيات الدفاع الذاتي
لديها. الاحداث والتطورات.
الامين العام للامم المتحدة
انطونيو جوتيريس يطالب الدول
الغنية بتقديم نصف دولار سنويا
للبلدان الاقل نموا. الرجل
الاصفر دونالد ترامب يتحدث انا
الوحيد الذي يمكنني ايقاف الحرب
العالمية. اذا اعيد انتخابي
ساوقف الحرب الاوكرانية خلال
اربع وعشرين ساعة فقط. العراق
يمنع دخول المشروبات الكحولية
بكافة انواعها. قرارات عراقية
بايقاف اعضاء حكومة رئيس الوزراء
العراقي السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
على خلفية قضايا فساد. احرج رئيس
الكونغو نظيره الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون على الهواء بعدما طلب من
فرنسا عدم التعامل بسلوية مع
افريقيا والافارقة قائلا تعاملوا
معنا باحترام. ضابط لبناني يشتبك
بالايدي مع ضابط اسرائيلي حاول
اختراق الحدود. بعد ان اعلنت
روسيا دخول القنابل التدميرية
الهائلة على خط في اوكرانيا؟ هل
تحضر موسكو لمفاجآت اكبر